Alan found 4 marbles
to add to his 5 marbles
currently in his pocket.
He then had a competition
with his friends
and tripled his marbles.
Write a numerical expression
to model the situation
without performing
any operations.
So let's think about
what's going on.
So he already had 5
marbles in his pocket.
And then he found 4 more
marbles to add to that.
So we can add the 4
marbles to the 5 marbles.
So 4 marbles plus the 5 marbles.
So that's what happens
after the first sentence.
He found 4 marbles to
add to his 5 marbles
currently in his pocket.
He then had a competition
with his friends
and tripled his marbles.
So this is how many marbles
he had before tripling.
And now he's
tripling his marbles.
So we want to multiply 3 times
the total number of marbles
he has now-- times 4 plus 5.
So this right over here is
the numerical expression
that models the situation
without performing
any operations.
We, of course, could then
actually calculate this.
He has 9 marbles
before tripling.
And then you multiply
it by 3 and he has 27.
But this is what
they're asking for.
They want us to write
this expression.